thank you
all three of you sort of speechless for
the moment you are a brilliant orator
Daniela my so I'm gonna open it up we've
got about 25 minutes or so before we
take a break and go to our breakout
rooms and I suspect there is going to be
no shortage of directions we could take
this conversation or questions and
thoughts people have in the room and
I'll just you know prompt you the more
you can also you know make this relevant
to kind of bring out how how what you've
heard is relevant to your own experience
to Toronto to your organization's the
people you serve I think that would
bring a lot of kind of richness to this
conversation as well and help us kind of
thread some of these these themes
through what we've just heard because
there's a lot of kind of connective
tissue between them that I think we'd
love to continue to surface so who would
like to start
thank you very much those were excellent
lectures and speeches and I learned a
lot I've been involved in New York
region since way back in 97 and with
Danieli as our lead we had the very
first earlier Center that dr. Fraser
master himself chosen for York Region so
that's how far back we go we go back a
long way Wow I'm miss Mannis and I'm
from the College of Family Physicians
and so I bring some of the medical
expertise and we've been working at it
from the medical perspective one of the
things that your region did back then
was they created something called
performanceplus schools when they looked
at the stats on their EQ AO stores and
looked at the high income in the low
income but then they tailored unique
solutions for each of the different
areas because some of the areas would
have a pocket of subsidized housing
another one would be cultural poverty
from immigrants and refugees and the
solution that worked for one group
didn't work for another in other parts
of York Region we found historic
generation after generation on social
assistance with poor literacy levels
dropping out of school early learning
disabilities and that was the solution
so we had to target them differently
from families where there might be drug
addiction or mental health issues versus
English as a second language and we were
getting a lot of well-educated parents
from overseas
who couldn't find jobs in their regular
occupations who had to get jobs just to
pay the bills but never but they and so
it was all different so I'm wondering
how those different types of poverty
might impact on all three of what all of
you said my first reaction is I was just
at a conference it was convened by the
Gates Foundation and the White House and
what they were talking about this was at
UCSF and it sounds weird when you first
hear it which is precision public health
right so we've heard in medicine
precision medicine we're tailing
tailoring the treatment to the genome
right and can we do that on a community
level cam and that sounds exactly being
ahead of the curve of what what you were
doing what you're proposing I I have not
seen in the u.s. that type of community
level targeting that's differentiated in
that way my guess is that you're a lot
further ahead here yeah I don't I don't
know how far ahead we are like I mean
how much further ahead we are but I
think it's interesting Pat that you know
if you stick around long enough in this
sector everything that's old becomes new
again so it's all good right because
that just sounds like community
development work where you tailor the to
the community to meet those needs and
and I think it worked in in York Region
at the time with the schools and I think
there's examples across all for all of
us on whether that works or not I think
the problem is we don't stick to it long
enough because there's all kinds of
proof that it takes up to 15 years to
even build centers connection capital
but because as a United Way we would be
a culprit of this as well
funding is so cyclical it's like getting
in
two years and then get the hell out and
if we just had the wherewithal to hang
in long enough and demonstrate long term
20 years that's the hope at least that's
my hope until I retire who else has a
question yeah my name is Dina Orman I'm
with Children Services with the city of
Toronto and I support the coordination
of the Toronto Child and Family network
thank you very much this was great I was
just wondering both Candice and Mario
with your research
have you found tools that have helped
particularly Mario with childcare
centers I'm wondering how that social
capital was built was it and and what
the different models of childcare were
maybe some of them were co-op and that's
why you know and there was some
requirements and parent interaction was
a little more intense than some
commercial or other other types of
operations and then Candice if there's
opportunities or tools or approaches to
mitigate the impacts that happen when
were in these mixed communities and
perceived inequalities exist so I
actually spend quite a bit of time
thinking about this and so to this
question the data I can bring are the
field-based data from the 24 centers I
was describing earlier one of the things
that we found and I should say that we
also did a representative samples based
survey of 300 centers across New York so
with the fieldwork and then we got a
sense of how much of what we're seeing
in the fieldwork was consistent across
centers in the city I would take kind of
two things one is I rarely saw any
centers in which directors effectively
build social capital by trying to build
social capital it almost never works and
many did so a lot of directors are
professionals who you know through I've
exposed to the social sciences are aware
of some aspect of the impact of social
capital I'm remembering one in a
predominately black high poverty
neighborhood
we're almost all of the children are
black almost all of them would qualify
for reduced free lunch if they were in
public school and she was frustrated
because she would try to run events and
you know pizza night and whatever to get
people to get to know each other because
he'd be useful and it never worked and
that was my experience some version of
that was my experience across the board
and the reason is pretty obvious in
retrospect everybody's busy I mean
nobody really I mean we're all busy I
mean I have seen the data and I would
have a and I rarely go to parties to
meet people if I'm you know doing other
things I just don't do it and so I think
that's actually really important but
then of course the second point of all
that and what what does work
consistently across the board what I
found was organizations that needed
parents to work on something that the
organization needed and then as a
byproduct of that effort the social
capital ended up being built so for
example there were highly
under-resourced organizations that
needed to fund that needed the funders
for examples like I didn't show you this
in the slides but he did the fundraise
to get a lot of the kids out to field
trips so in New York if you haven't been
to New York that's of course the high
densities highly dense city like Toronto
is but a lot of the children in the
low-income neighborhoods never see green
space just you know there might be four
or five years old that I've never seen a
park other than the local kind of half
an acre a little park in their
neighborhood I've never seen animals
other than sort of rodents have never
know it's true I've never seen a farm
and so there were several centers that
had as a professional mission on the
part of the directors to get the kids
exposed five six times a year the kids
would have to get out of the city that
costs money
it also requires people so the child the
adult child ratio in a classroom can be
much lower than it can be outside in the
field where you you know the kids will
stick their hands in animal cages and so
on you just need more bodies so the
center's organize themselves to run a
field trips or to fundraise for a new
swing set
I mean this all sounds very trivial but
it's actually very common to you know
reef you know reread fix the the
playground outside they were playing in
hard asphalt how do we get money for
that and all of those activities
required parents to figure it out to
show up we needed a ton of volunteers to
run a filter to the zoo and it was in
the process of that that people on the
ended up building a social capital that
incidentally ended up actually being
really good for people's well-being so
consistently when I talk about this the
one message I would say is I would not
even bother with the parties and the
get-togethers it's not going to work
especially among sort of mothers of
longing you saw the figures they're
working about and large or they were in
school or they have work requirements
that they're on in the United States and
their assistance but the sort of
extracurricular so to speak which
everybody believes in ended up
consistently working and we have I mean
if he if we email me I mean I can show
you actually data we know how many
childcare centers what the average how
many field trips for example the average
soccer center did and how many did went
to the zoo and so on and there are
strong associations in a survey data
between that on the extent to which the
parents ended up building social capital
so I would say it's that sort of the
core mission is that sort of water say
that the organization needs anyway for
its mission that could be helped by
social good thank you
there was a second question for you yeah
I think I agree social capital is
something that happens while you're
doing something else right there I think
there's kind of two examples that come
to mind one that's kind of interesting
have you heard of the walking school bus
right so I mean this has gotten a lot of
attention both through the benefits or
physical fitness where you know routes
that kids used to run so there's those
kinds of things where you know one of
the benefits as the parents get to know
each other and do these exact things but
the the the thing that came to mind for
me around what I spent a lot of time
thinking about is kind of increasing
kids feeling of belonging right and
feeling like they're supported or that
they belong in a space and in the u.s.
anyway there is a number of
interventions or happen with
first-generation college students that
are very kind of brief psychological
interventions around making the
individual who's coming in who may be a
first-generation student may not know a
lot of people may not feel like they
belong there
a brief intervention which tells them
basically two things one most people
feel this way and it's gonna get better
right and then they tell the next cohort
that comes in and and so there's also
been a little bit Mitch but these are
very kind of brief interventions
focusing on those two things and now I
hesitate in saying this because
interventions that kind of target the
child in a world that's unjust aren't
something that I would put my full stake
in right I mean we need to change the
structures and build the community but
you know are there opportunities to
recognize that kids might feel like they
don't belong or they don't have a
network and to change their help to
change their perspective on that or they
build their confidence to to form those
bonds leave for Joan's pediatrician and
sick children and from the steering
committee have you seen any levers or
ways to engage people with time and
money you know sort of for example the
retired rich in activities with
disadvantaged neighborhoods improving
either their understanding of the
situation or action that they might take
in literacy literacy or skill building I
had heard for example around the
understanding bit in Ottawa United Way
had done seeing is believing tours some
time ago I'd be interested in capacity
building through the people with time
and money yeah I think we we have all
kinds of opportunities for people to
engage in our work whether it's at an
individual agency or at a larger scale a
neighborhood involvement or a policy
work and I think to what we've just
heard the real way to engage them into
the community long term is to help them
solve an issue or get them involved in a
you know volunteer capacity and then you
unleash that you know I don't know
around the retirees if that's what you
were leaning in on I mean it's it's we
found at least that United Way that once
they leave the workplace and they get
involved in other things and not
necessarily through us but I'm sure
they're connected to community and
others yeah it does kind of go to that
broader question there's there's
definitely a theme about the with
coming from within and so where where
are there opportunities for sort of
those outside of communities to to
support them I don't know if Mario can
does have examples of where that's been
helpful or if really kind of a key
message here is it really has to start
from within I haven't seen it in the
context of for example head starts or
even other kinds of local organizations
I have seen it in the context of
business development where basically
former managers or CEO sometimes will
basically try to mentor young people but
I actually think it's a it's a really
good idea in this particular context you
know you can imagine especially as baby
boomers sell their big houses in the
suburbs and take the cash and move into
the city which is happening in Boston a
lot of sort of other major cities
they've heard of reconnecting to their
life long metropolitan areas in a
different way and I think using those
resources to connect through chakra
centers through local community
organizations through churches to bring
that skill set back into the communities
in the Leadership Forum I think it's a
great idea actually I should say there's
one example I saw of this I know that I
think about it there's a in a
neighborhood called via Victoria in
Boston which is a predominately Porto
Rican housing project I studied many
years ago they have they have a local
community organization with a board of
directors that was traditionally based
on local residents so this is a housing
complex
everybody was low income in the last few
years and I know this because I was
asked to join the board they've tried to
expand the community organizations are
bringing leaders from the community as a
way of do I'm not retired but as a way
of doing a version of what you're not
yet no thank goodness I mean I mean
retiring is fun I'm sure but what I'm
say it's a version of what you're
talking about Regan sort of bringing
skill sets from a different part of so
the life course or people in a different
part of the income distribution into
communities and that might be an example
of something kind of like what you're
describing just a comment on that as
Mary was talking I mean it requires
support and funding and I'm not
suggesting that everything we do
requires money but
when you look at the agencies and the
network of the nonprofit's that we're
referring to they're having a hard time
keeping their lights on and providing
programming and as much as they'd love
to embrace the abundance of volunteers
you have to work with them manage them
and make it a meaningful experience and
so how you bring them in and make it
meaningful requires often support and
skills made up to to engage volunteers
in the extreme than ones that you're
describing as sort of integrated and
thoughtful and research-based in
evidence-based yeah okay others yeah hi
I'm Suzanne I'm from Children's Services
as well with the City of Toronto Candice
for yourself I was fascinated actually
with your I'm going away I'm gonna look
it up I want to read through it all but
particularly when you were talking about
the perceptions that children have of
themselves and where they see themselves
on the social ladder in the power of
that own self perception leading to
various different signs and in that
direct connection with them signs of
well-being I'm wondering if you can if
if you looked at this in your study if
you looked at some of the other
contributing factors to where children
were placing themselves so within the
context of being a mixed neighborhood
and thinking about this in you know kids
are seeing exposure all the time to
various levels of income through their
TV through social media it's in their
face all the time
so I'm wondering about what it is on one
hand about being within a neighborhood
that really you know being side by side
and also whether the difference between
the Association and the social position
they place on themselves versus
something more direct discriminatory
like having a poor door where it's very
much you're being told you are different
even though you're sitting side by side
so yeah my questions really about those
contributing factors so I think what we
documented it as on from of this
trajectory in the Arkham what I didn't
show you today was evidence of a
developmental evolution so when does
this first come online
and it seems to be around mid
adolescence that this becomes very
predictive so kids get a little more
accurately calibrated because they're
judging their family's social position
right and then and then so the question
after we figure out okay it's not just a
negative perception it's like something
about how the kid is encoding where they
feel they belong in this water is now
predicting health outcomes you know
their physical health their mental
health and that's that's pretty robust
so the next question is exactly what you
said what predicts that and and so what
we see is that the composition of people
around them so how much income they have
that predicts but what we couldn't find
in the British study was these were long
years between assessments so what we've
done and work that I didn't talk about
here is we actually follow kids around
on their mobile phones and we get daily
reports of their experiences around
perceived discrimination around
interactions around positive negative
spirits of where they are and so we're
trying to piece that together in terms
of kind of daily feelings of
belongingness and belonging and kind of
at what point and what age and and
whether this is state you know a stable
thing you know does it change depending
on those experiences and can we move it
a little so I don't have the answer that
second part I know that the inequality
piece you know just living around people
does tend to move where you place
yourself on the ladder but I don't know
kind of on a daily level yet what's the
underlying hypothesis there was kind of
tracking the data of them using their
phone what are you hoping to learn from
that right so we we look at a couple
things so we get the first thing is
understanding you know we study kid kids
experiences in poverty everyone has
probably heard about the forty million
word gap right so lower versus higher
income kids are exposed to just more
words and that predicts okay so we're
interested in something that Clyde
herzman calls a drip drip drip of daily
life so what does it look what are the
exhale experiences of living in poverty
for these kids in terms of their
exposure to positive and negative
interactions to bullying to kind of
other kinds of experiences what are
their travel spaces how do those differ
and who's aware they're spending their
time
so kind of get them gave at higher
resolution and in that process we've
been thinking a lot about you know kind
of how they view themselves in terms of
relative to others is that a stable
trait of the individual or does that
change depending on what kind of
experiences they have our attractions
those days oh and the phones are just a
very good way to connect with kids hi
there my name is Bill Watson I'm a
family doc at st. Mike's which is a few
blocks away from here this is
fascinating stuff I'm a guy who works in
the trenches with families and kids and
with mixed incomes all over the map and
the kinds of health problems I'm seeing
coming up upstream are particularly
things like screen time social media
bullying mental health issues in kids
and adolescents and and then childhood
obesity so those are the big big issues
that I see in the last 35 years hate to
say it coming upstream and I think we
need to address some of those issues and
they they transcend income as well
they're there for families but also rich
families so I'm wondering if you have
any thoughts on some of those areas yeah
I'll just say I think that um you're
right and then technology using concerns
over that kind of span the SES spectrum
I think what people are concerned about
now is that what what's been termed a
new digital divide and it children from
low-income households are spending a lot
more time online but a lot more
unsupervised time so children from
higher SES households have a parent
there that's really mediating in many
cases limiting the screen time for
especially for younger kids and then
also guiding access so the concern is
that could be amplifying kind of
educational performance and inequalities
across across group so that's one of the
concerns along SES but you're right and
that we've seen rising rates of
childhood obesity across the spectrum
but the large scale that's a lot of
those problems are concentrated among
low SES kids they experience a greater
burden as you know
Danyelle anything on that one yeah I
could comment a little under sort of
another part of what you talked about
which is sort of the bullying and
essentially violence one other
interesting thing that's happened in the
u.s. is that over the last twenty five
twenty to twenty-five years in cities
the violence rates have pretty much
declined but what's interesting is that
decline at different rates in different
cities and in the last two to three
years the inched back up in about a
quarter of the large cities so Chicago's
an example and I just finished a study I
looked at children in elementary school
in Chicago so the this were sixth
seventh and eighth graders and what was
interesting is very consistent with your
point which is we began the study in a
context in which there was a lot of
mobility in Chicago Public Schools so
kids are turning in and out of schools
not because they get kicked out because
people are moving so much because the
housing projects are getting demolished
and they have to find a new place to
live we were interested in understanding
how this affected friendship formation
among children and what was interesting
is we began and we began this pilot
study looking just as fiendish at
friendship formation and the impact of
mobility and it turns out that the
mobility didn't monitor almost at all
because everybody was concerned with
violence
boys and girls regardless of age and by
by age as early as 11 they had a doubt
that something that I had never seen in
the literature on friendship formation
among children so friendship formation
among children and much of the work has
focused on two things first it tends to
be highly effective as opposed to
instrumental in nature so kids formed
friends based on basically whether they
like you or not but second a lot of that
has to do with what sociologist called
homophily or the tendency of people to
associate with those who resemble them
so you play soccer I play soccer will
become friends you like video games or
like video games you like Barbies I like
Barbies or whatever it is what we're
seeing is almost none of that among
these kids and rather than effective
their approach was strategic so they
avoided people they specifically sought
out people who were big and good
literally protect them and fistfights
they tested people so a kid would start
a rumor and only tell that one other kid
who seems like he wants to be my friend
to see if it comes back to me just 11
years old a lot is extremely strategic
and distrustful attitude towards
friendship formation I'm part of the
thing that and I have I have not seen
versions of this in the gang literature
among older kids but the majority of
these kids in fact the majority of kids
in inner-city neighborhoods are not in
gangs and but one of the but I have not
seen this reported and one of the things
I'm actually quite concerned about is
this is the period where as we've just
heard you're you're not just making
friends but you're learning how to make
friends you're learning how to relate to
others you're Sakura appeared in terms
of association socio-emotional
development of people i can't imagine
when they're 2025 years old and trying
to build romantic relationships and
professional relationships at work and
so on how that's going to have an impact
so that's the aspect of what you talked
about that I have seen to me bullying is
just a different term from our kind of
violence that some kids are experiencing
in very poor neighborhoods hi I'm Matt
Hilde are also with Toronto Children's
Services my question I think maybe trust
to span all three of you but the issue
of mixed income neighborhoods is a
really hot topic here in the City of
Toronto and I think broadly have been
planning or generally and I think the
point where Candice and Mario your
research crosses is this social capital
across class divides question and I just
wanted to kind of raise that question
because that's ostensibly the benefit of
these mixed income neighborhoods some
kind of questionable theories around
social uplift I wonder if you can speak
to that and I think it also speaks to
this issue of community and what
constitutes a community within space
just briefly I cannot recount as his
mind however unfortunately I can read
the literature which he can also read
and I can tell you that what you
described is something that was very
much a part of the conversation 15 20
years ago the idea that it makes think
in communities among the things that
would happen is the poor would no longer
be socially isolated because now having
a connected socially to the people in
their neighborhoods they would have
access to the information this is where
about jobs the role models for the kids
makes other kinds of resources that are
not part of the typical networks I have
not seen every any evidence at all of
that ever happening I have not seen it
perhaps it has happened in some cases to
just give you an example and if you're
interested in this work Roberts askin at
the University of Chicago has done quite
a bit on this who has looked and
actually also in some sense is Mary
Pattillo they have looked at mixed
income context in Chicago that were
designed precisely with this idea in my
different language but it was the same
idea and typically what happens is some
version of what you just heard described
exclusion people stick within their own
social circles economic circles within
the neighborhood sometimes there's
cultural conflict I haven't seen much
evidence of the thing that people were
hoping for right so I think it's a in
some ways it's a romantic vision right
and it's been around for a long time and
and thinking about you know you see
remnants of this and the charter school
movement in the United States of
enclaves of individuals it's you know in
some ways the schooling system the
attempts to do economically racially
makes schools as a result of even more
segregated schools and some of that is
through kind of the white flight to
suburbs some of that is through
communities wanting to take back control
and education of their their children
and feel like they want their children
to be in communities where they're
supported and if you in a positive light
so there's it's it's complicated I think
that the main point that I was trying to
make in this presentation was that we
can't just get to the point we feel
really good about economically makes
communities when they happen and they're
held up as success stories and whenever
I hear that story I start to listen very
carefully to to what the metrics are and
I think one of the metrics just has to
be hard outcomes on health on mental
health on educational test scores for
kids and thinking exactly about these
gaps and this heterogeneity and what the
composition of those schools are and
maybe will find you know and this is
kind of the Clyde herzman idea when you
map communities and you find these
hotspots of successful communities that
have done that and what can we learn
from those case studies of how
people done that but I haven't seen the
kind of great examples that we would
like to well what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take a break for about 10
minutes and then we're gonna have a
chance to kind of keep digging into this
with three kind of themes in mind okay
so for those of you who want to spend
some more time talking about child
health well-being socioeconomic status
some of what you've heard from Candace
around sort of distance and and the
impact of that there's kind of a couple
of questions that will guide that group
in what ways does socioeconomic status
impact child health and well-being and
this is really the chance for to hear
from you on what you've seen and
experienced and what questions you have
what tools approaches and resources can
be used to mitigate the impact of
poverty on child health and well-being
what are you doing what are you
experiencing what thoughts and ideas do
you have we'd love to bring those back
Candace will join that group but but it
isn't intended to be another kind of 45
minutes of Q&A with Candace although
she'll start by sharing any additional
ideas or answering any questions that
group has but then we've got a
facilitator in each of these groups
that's really going to be be there to
make sure that we're you know everyone's
getting a chance to share and learn from
each other
similarly Mari will join the second
group social connections social capital
continuing to discuss some some of what
we've started here and you can take it
in whatever direction makes sense to the
group so how does increasing social
capital mitigate the effects of poverty
and other deprivation indicators will be
kind of the guiding question and and and
as concrete as you can get in terms of a
sort of a generative discussion on what
are some of the strategies to build a
measure social capital we've obviously
touched on a whole host here what other
ones do people know what other kind of
concerns and challenges come up
neighborhoods I think we've just really
skimmed the surface of some of the work
that Danielle E and United Way more
broadly has been doing York Region
Toronto and Beyond around neighborhood
success there was some pre reading on
their neighborhood strategy so that's
really a chance to to talk about
neighborhoods overall and and what are
some of those those strategies that are
mitigating the effects of poverty on
child outcomes and what are some tools
and approaches that you've all seen and
then this last one Elaine's going to
lead
and and and I know your organization has
spent quite a bit of time both in the
context of raising the village and
beyond
you know grappling with this issue of
how do cities allocate resources to try
to you know address these well-being
outcomes and so this is really a chance
to talk about some of the challenges
that are coming up for you and your work
around you know how do you allocate
limited funds more equitably what tools
and approaches exist to do this and I
know a lot of organizations certainly
that I work with really struggle with
this this this idea of universal or
universally targeted programs and and
how do you sort of deal with equitable
equitable issues when you're talking
about Universal programs and they're
sort of a parallel I think as we're
talking about mixed mixed housing and
kind of Universal programs and what are
some of the sort of strengths and
drawbacks of that so I think that'll be
an interesting dimension of a
conversation to bring back after the
breakout groups to so here's how it's
gonna go we're gonna have a facilitator
and and everyone all of the facilitators
are from Toronto Child and Family
network so thank you for for being here
today to facilitate those conversations
and each of the four groups will also
have a scribe or a reporter who's going
to capture the insight so we won't be
able to cover everything obviously
you're gonna come you're gonna you're
gonna be discussing in your small groups
so someone will be there to capture it
and we'll come back and really just
share some of the highlights of the
conversation